the following trailer is rated as for
spoilers
[Music]
you've seen Decades of Star Wars films
and shows all leading up to this moment
or more likely you bounce sometime
around rise of Skywalker in the Boba
Fett show
[Music]
now watch the franchise plot aimlessly
along while Disney scans the Galaxy for
anyone to make them a decent movie again
it's gonna be a while folks and after
this season they might put favreaux in
carbonite too hey Google
this isn't working for me
same the Mandalorian season three
Bounty Hunter turned many din jarin is
back and just like Star Wars fans he's
not 100 sure what he's still doing here
I thought you had completed your mission
in this grab bag of a season with a
little bit of rejoining his church group
you are redeemed a bit about retaking
planet Mandalore it is time to retake
Mandalore a dash of dark cloning
a pinch of piracy we're pirate king gory
and shards men now you'll answer to him
and a death star's worth of real estate
talk there's a beautiful parcel
available right down here by the flats
let's move the trade District closer to
the shipping terminals grief carga is
offered me attractive land on his
independent World hereby seed all Land
from the Western lava Flats to Bullock
Canyon I want to give you this deed to a
cabin just outside of town I can set you
up with a prime tract right over by the
hot springs remember this season takes
place after Dan finds the darksaber but
before he closed escrow on a two-bedroom
in Navarro you love Pedro Pascal as a
Gruff older guy taking a little VIP
across a dangerous landscape you love
watching him overcome his troubled past
to form a makeshift family with his
charge you love when he joins with an
equally grow female counterpart who
comes to see the value of his mission
and you love taking diversions from the
a story for one-off episodes that follow
the people they encounter on their
travels so yeah that's that show again
sorry for repeating ourselves but so do
they constantly this is the way this is
the way this is the way this is the way
way this is the way this is the way this
is the way this is the way this is the
is the way this is the way
this is the way
after boarding ways with baby Yoda in
season two Disney took one look at the
toy sales and said
um no no it may not be super clear while
they're still together make up your mind
whether he's an actual baby or just a
baby they're forcing to be a Child
Soldier he is too small time is Ward
proceed
and whether it's special effects and
make it move or just a Target doll they
bought to Chuck around said
[Music]
oh it's so fast the one thing we do know
is his name baby Yoda his name grogu no
if you say so speaking of toys meet
every other Mandalorian figure so
separately battery's Not Included the
Jedi aren't the only reclusive maybe
celibate religious sect with a thing for
Orphan boys the words of the Creed shall
be forever forged in my heart collect a
whole clan full of these posable
disposables like the armorer one of the
deadliest Hammer fighters in pop culture
non-inscest division
come on
pause vizsler John favreau's literal
self-insert who spawns with the op chain
God and still can't survive the season
and in a series all about running
errands you just know they're gonna stop
for some Starbucks along the way rejoin
Boca tan just kind of sitting around
waiting for an adventure to happen until
she's accidentally baptized in the
waters of Lake Minnetonka and gets
called to resolve mandalore's deep
cultural divides ninety percent of which
are helmet based you have removed your
helmet I removed my helmet and now I'm
in apostate I'm guessing that helmet
isn't coming off again and have you
removed your helmet since how do you eat
when other people are around you don't
when you get your food you go off to
find a place where you can take off your
helmet remove your helmet oh
helmet is so big it will go smoother if
you keep your helmet on trust me sure
you don't have to wear the helmet at all
times but listen to your boy Pedro he
knows what's up
once you're done suffering through
baby's first and or episode Empire
rebels new Republic I can't keep track
one episode so corny you'll barely
notice it's about the heroes putting
down a slave rebellion is there no room
for a little bit of forgiveness in a
galaxy so vast and like five different
episodes where a giant monster pops out
and says boo
oh
finally thrill at the return of moff
Gideon he's back with a brand new super
suit I have created the Next Generation
Dark Trooper suit and an all-consuming
purpose to steer this show to where Dave
baloney is more comfortable the
cartoons Grand Admiral thrawn's return
will Herald in the re-emergence of our
military and provide commandant huts
enough time to deliver on Project
Necromancer can can I just go so scale
back your expectations after Andor way
back if that is at the clock calling the
stiffly slimy because even though Star
Wars is for everyone Disney has lost
sight of what made it special in the
first place
going the away every once in a
while
starring the blast of us now that I have
my new body I can defeat those blasted
Turtles three Settlers of Catan Alan
Smithy it's free real estate turn your
head and moth The Spy Who bugged me the
Clone Wars outer rims convenience what
are you getting a gun for in case
someone steps to you Snoop Dogg best of
the best a pirates leave for me this is
not the greatest Star Wars character in
the world this is just a tribute fluted
and booted it and as Tim Meadows
considered a cameo or just an actor
who's still getting work these days
time for din-din
okay it's official the prequels did look
better despite coming out 20 years ago
[Applause]
[Music]
this season may have been a letdown but
Jedi Survivor has me Swinging to pretend
lightsaber around and scaring my cat all
over again Gamespot showed the game to a
real-life swordmaster to evaluate the
lightsaber combat Styles and it's as
satisfyingly nerdy as it sounds click
the Box on the right to watch now till
next time take care of yourself and each
other